as vaccine mandates hit home police
departments begin firing cops on mass
the new york city council removes a
statue of thomas jefferson and joe biden
admits that the teachers unions run the
show i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
then we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
that everybody wants your data we're
talking hackers want your data your isps
want your data the websites you visit
they want your data everybody wants your
data
that's not their business your data is
your business which is why you should
protect yourself when you are online the
same way that i do by using express vpn
you know a single company controls 90 of
internet searches runs your email
service gets to track everything you do
on your smartphone why not protect all
of that data using expressvpn because
pretty much your entire life is on the
internet when you run express vpn on
your device however the software hides
your ip address something big tech can
use to personally identify you so
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and sell to advertisers expressvpn
also encrypts 100 of your internet data
to keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers on your network an
expressvpn does all of that without
slowing your connection that's why it's
rated the number one vpn service by cnet
and tech radar what i like most about
expressvpn super easy to use you can
download it with one click of a button
and then you hit a button and now it's
working on your phone or on your
computer and now you are protected stop
handing over your personal data to the
big tech monopoly or the hackers or to
anybody else protect yourself with the
vpn i trust visit
expressvpn.com that's exp our ess
vpn.com3 extra months for free
expressvpn.com
to learn more alrighty so we have been
told by joe biden that these vaccine
mandates are going to get us out of the
pandemic now what's amazing about that
is that the pandemic for all intents and
purposes has basically been over in
terms of public policy since the
vaccines were rolled out despite all of
the outside panic that you see in the
news every day and the media can't
decide whether the vaccines are super
effective or super ineffective they
can't decide whether to scare you about
why you need to take a booster or
whether to tell you how effective the
vaccines are which is why people are
confused and people have questions the
media have done a terrible job and the
public health experts have done a
terrible job and then joe biden says and
then on the basis of your chaotic
understanding of what's going on i'm
going to cram down one size fits all no
natural immunity exemptions for vaccine
mandates
i'm going to encourage businesses to do
the same thing no religious exemptions
no personal exemptions like nothing
right and why are you getting so
divisive about all this why are you
getting so divisive well when you do all
of that the predictable result is that
people harden their resistance
especially because they figure quite
correctly that as time goes on and as
the effect of the pandemic wane and as
more and more people have either natural
immunity or covet immunity via the
vaccine that all of this is just going
to fall apart right there's not going to
be a regime where a year from now or two
years from now people are still using
vaccine passports it's not going to be a
thing it's just going to become a
background part of daily life people
will have accepted the risk for the most
part into their daily lives how do i
know this because it's already happened
in large swaths of the country and in
florida where i live people for a year
have already accepted that covert was
just a part of the background risk of
daily life and you mitigated that risk
as you saw fit if you were really
worried you were canned 95 if you
weren't all that worried you wore a
cloth mask or no mask at all and then
once the vaccines were available pretty
much everybody was like okay if i want
to take the vaccine i will and then i'll
get back to my regular life or i never
wanted to take the vaccine and i'll get
back to my regular life and everybody
went back to their regular life again i
keep citing the stat because nobody on
the left seems to want to deal with the
simple fact that if this is a quote
unquote pandemic of the unvaxed and the
unvaccinated the real problem you're
going to have to explain why this is an
economic downturn of the blue states and
why this is a why this is a
psychological worry point for the vast
if you're talking about illogic i
understand the logic of
the the take that it is illogical for
people who are 70 years old not to take
the vaccine i get that i agree with that
but it is just as illogical for people
who are fully vast to go around worried
day in and day out they're going to die
of covert unless they have a serious
pre-existing health condition and it is
just as illogical to say that once you
are vast you need to worry about the
unvex infecting you and it is just as
illogical as all of that to say that you
need hard lockdown economic measures and
vaccine passports that suppress the
economy while the vaccines are already
available so the step the left refuses
to deal with is the simple fact that the
pandemic may be a pandemic of the unvacs
but the economic meltdown is an economic
meltdown of the blue states again the
worst states in the united states in
terms of unemployment and this has been
true for a while are all blue states the
best states in terms of unemployment are
all red states of the top 23 states in
terms of employment rate
17 are red four are purple two are blue
and in terms of the bottom ten states if
you include washington dc in that count
you're talking about all ten being blue
okay the reason for that is pretty
obvious and that is
this is no longer about anything other
than failure to calculate risk and
failure to assess risk and failure to
live with risk
and so you have this bizarre situation
in which governmental actors
particularly in blue areas are
attempting to cram down on some of the
healthiest populations
their version of what reality ought to
look like and they are willing to
undergo they're actually willing to
increase the risk for their citizens
in order to mitigate a risk that really
is not their business and also is not
really an issue okay in police
departments all over the united states
you know how vaccine mandates being put
on police officers all over the united
states
this is a bizarre take
so the idea is that you would rather
have people not available to answer 911
calls then to have the person who shows
up at the 911 call not even be infected
with kovid just not be vaccinated for
covid
that is the logic that is currently
being used so in order to mitigate
against a virus that is going to kill in
the age group of cops which is probably
between 20 and 40 for the most part in
an age group where maybe three out of a
thousand people who get coveted are
going to die to mitigate against that
you are going to make sure that if
somebody calls 911
has the possibility of carrying that
is going to show up for the 9-1-1 call
and so what you're seeing is literally
hundreds of police officers across the
nation who are dumping out
this is most obvious in chicago where
literally hundreds and hundreds of
officers are pushing back and saying
they're not going to take the vaccine
despite lori lightfoot's insistence that
they do again a lot of that has to do
with the public health failures here
of lori lightfoot who throughout the
pandemic has been a hypocrite remember
that she went she got her hair done when
nobody else was allowed to get their
hair done remember that she's showing up
to large parties on masks when
supposedly that's really really bad well
now apparently the back and forth
between the mayor and the chicago police
union continues according to cbs local
with the city sending out a flurry of
emails and memos as its vaccine mandate
enters its first full week in effect
cbs 2's
mugo odigwe obtained the latest
threatening memo sent out to officers at
least two memos have gone out since
friday's deadline for all city workers
to report their vaccination status to
the city but the fraternal order of
police president john catinsera said
thousands of officers are still refusing
to do so
he said the unofficial number we have is
about 3 200. one-third of the entire
department
kansera says the demand is illegal
because the city didn't negotiate terms
with the union he said officers who are
still refusing to report vaccination
status will be called in by supervisors
on monday and once again will be asked
to comply with mandate
if they refuse it sounds like they're
going to go into no pay status effective
immediately so they'll essentially be
suspended
captain xero says all those things are
changing your employment policies you
have to negotiate with us what that
looks like the city has refused to do
that
the latest memo involves consequences
officers could face if they don't follow
the city of chicago's vaccination policy
any such officers will become subject to
a disciplinary investigation that could
result in a penalty up to and including
separation from chicago pd so you have
people who are being shot on mass every
weekend in chicago and lori lightfoot is
threatening to fire literally 3 200
members of the chicago pd if they don't
turn in their vaccination status
here is lori lightfoot then attacking
the union for all of this not her own
stupid policy
we believe that the fop leadership is
trying to foment in a legal workstop it
could shrink pure and simple we've laid
that out in the materials um and we're
not just we're not having that the
contract is clear and it's been known
for a long time uh the police unions are
not authorized to strike it's in their
collective bargaining agreement it's a
matter of state law what we've seen from
uh the fraternal order of police in
particular leadership is a lot of
misinformation a lot of half truths and
frankly flat out lies in order to induce
an insurrection uh and we're not having
that it's an insurrection okay we're
just going to use this word now
insurrection to mean things that are not
an insurrection okay now listen i'm very
much against public sector unions as a
general matter because you're bargaining
against the taxpayer yeah i think that
the notion that you can have public
servants who are being paid by the
taxpayers striking
not against
i mean against the general public that
is what a strike against the taxpayers
is when you do this sort of stuff
however lori lightfoot had no
ideological problems with any of that
until five minutes ago when you had
teachers walking off the job in chicago
she was perfectly sanguine about all of
that she's just mad because they're
showing her up she's just angry because
her rule is stupid and nobody wants to
follow it and it's not just lori
lightfoot in chicago who is a coveted
hypocrite all on her own
it's also san francisco according to cbs
local in san francisco the deadline for
san francisco's first responders to show
proof of vaccination has come on comment
and gone on thursday it appeared the
mandate has drastically improved the
latest vaccination numbers among city
employees and police officers this is
what they were saying as of late last
week
however however the number of san
francisco police department officers
is still
75 76 those officers are being placed on
administrative leave while waiting for
hearings on their individual cases and
this has some pretty significant
consequences nearly 200 officers have
applied for medical or religious
exemptions it's unclear how many have
been approved by the city how bad are
things according to cbs san francisco
some calls are just going to get left
unanswered
as october is a busy month and the
giants and dodgers will play here at
game five at oracle park tomorrow and
they'll be officers patrolling inside
and outside of this area now with fewer
officers on the job the police officers
association says there may be some calls
that will be left unanswered
um that's not good okay so you live in a
city you're a citizen of that city right
you're a taxpayer of that city your
taxes go to pay for the police officers
and the police officers are there
they're saying we're happy to do our
jobs i just don't want to get vaccinated
and if you want to get vaccinated you
can because you're a responsible adult
enjoy
okay and
as a taxpayer i just have a question
here's your choice would you rather have
no cops or would you rather have cops
we tried to fund the police last year it
didn't go well so now they're trying
vaccinate the police i guess as an
alternative it's an alternative radical
policy in all these blue cities and it's
going to go similarly it turns out no
matter the reason for the cop shortages
cop shortages result in higher rates of
crime in seattle things are coming to a
head
many seattle police officers have been
quitting
a huge number of seattle police officers
are leaving the force there's already a
message a massive seattle police
department shortage at this point
i mean that's been going on for for
literally a year and a half
and there are probably hundreds of
officers short in seattle
there's some video of a washington cia
of a washington state patrol officer who
went this went viral the other day
because he started ripping on jay inslee
the governor who has been pushing a
state vaccine mandate
and um he
he rented as he quit basically
this is my final sign off after 22 years
of serving the citizens of the state of
washington
um being asked to leave because i am
dirty
numerous fatalities
injuries i've worked sick i've played
sick
we've buried lots of friends over these
years i'd like to thank you guys i'd
like to thank the
citizens of yakima county as well as my
fellow officers within the valley i wish
i could say more but um this is it so
state 1034 this is the last time you'll
hear me in a state patrol car
and jansley can kiss my
a lot of police officers feeling this
way so you have public officials who've
been undermining the ability of police
to do their jobs for years and years and
years and now telling them they must
vaccinate it and must vaccinate and a
lot of seattle pd are like we're just
not going to do it and so there's been a
spate of seattle police officers who
have been flying don't tread on me flags
on their cars a bunch of pictures of
this emerging from seattle by the way
this is just a perfect encapsulation of
seattle the seattle police are under
attack
and have been attacked by public
officials for years right i mean you
literally had the mayor of seattle last
year declare that a full takeover of
four city blocks called chas chop was
totally fine because the police were so
bad so now you have the police driving
around no don't try on me flags stuck to
their cars and in the background of half
of these pictures you can see homeless
tents they're just giant tents because
this is what has happened in our major
cities lawlessness abounds and the cops
are under assault
national police association president
betsy brantner smith retired police
sergeant told fox news on monday she
anticipates some costly litigation as
far as more police officers pushing back
than what the city administration
understands before monday's deadline the
seattle police officer's guild president
mike solin said the seattle police
department had already lost some 300
officers over the past 18 months he said
he anticipated another mass exodus in
the coming week
okay it is not j and it's all across the
country in leesburg virginia a police
officer named josh carter testified in
front of the city council about the
vaccine mandates and he was saying you
guys are going to decimate the
pd this decision has the potential to
decimate lpd
our town could lose a lot of amazing
police officers if you decide to move
forward with mandating this vaccine the
loss of officers is on you
and i'm gonna come back and ask what
your plan is to keep my family and my
neighbors safe
hey and this is right and by the way
it's extending not only to local pedia
it's extending to things like the navy
seals
so you've got the chinese firing
hypersonic missiles designed to strike
the united states and we here in the
united states are fully concerned with
tearing down statues of thomas jefferson
and making sure that we decimate the
navy seal ranks so that the healthy
literally the healthiest people alive on
planet earth
don't die from covet which they by
virtually all available data were not
going to die from anyway or had a very
minimal chance of dying from anyway all
right we're going to see more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
your sleep quality so as you know when
you have young kids your sleep quality
is often a question right you're up at
all hours with them but in those moments
when you finally do get slide down you
better go to sleep fast because the
clock is a ticking let me tell you i
rely on my helix sleep mattress it was
made just for me helix sleep has a quiz
it takes just two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with helix you're
getting a mattress you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep everybody
is unique helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains even
a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again you've got a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will helix even has financing options
and flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away just go
to helixleak.com ben take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that'll
give you the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixleep.com
ben hey so this is now even extending to
the navy seals the department of defense
has now put out a full-on
memo about all of this suggesting quote
in order to maximize readiness it is the
policy goal of the us navy to achieve a
fully vaccinated force against the
persistent and lethal threat of covid
19.
in support of the above stated policy
and as directed by the secretary of the
navy's lawful order the navy has
commenced a mandatory vaccine and
vaccination campaign
navy service members refusing the
covenant 19 vaccination absent a pending
or approved exemption shall be processed
for administrative separation
per this administrative order and
supporting references to ensure a fair
and consistent process separation
determinations will be centralized under
the ccda as outlined in the paragraphs
below and talk about the fact the vast
majority of people have decided to go
ahead and vaccinate which is not really
a shock because the truth is that when
you enter the armed services you are
required to have a lot of different
vaccinations so for a lot of people they
don't think it's that big a deal and as
i've said before
you know if you're an adult and you're
above the age of 20 your chances of
getting an adverse effect from the
vaccine are much lower than your chances
of getting an adverse effect from covet
itself so it makes some sense to
vaccinate if you are over the age of 20.
it may even make some sense to vaccinate
with one dose between the ages of 12 and
19. it makes increasingly less sense as
you get younger and younger because the
fact is that the vaccines on young kids
have really not there's no longitudinal
data and the threat of cova to very
small children is very minimal according
to the best available statistics
certainly in terms of mortality
okay but
specifically targeting the most fit
people in the navy and saying that the
navy seals and saying that those people
could have to pay for their own training
or have to or have to
refund the training funds that were
dedicated to them is kind of crazy
michael berry first liberty institute's
general counsel and lieutenant colonel
in the us marine corps reserve he says
purging our military of its elite
service members is detrimental to
national security doing so because the
commander-in-chief refuses to
accommodate the religious convictions is
abhorrent to the constitution their
years of experience and leadership and
service to our nation is immeasurable
and irreplaceable remove a seal from
special warfare reduces salary force him
to repay his training that's purely
vindictive and punitive and it's illegal
this has this has nothing to do with a
virus
again what does this have to do with
military readiness
you know when you hire cops the general
idea is they're going to lower crime
not that you can force them to vaccinate
for a disease that is very unlikely to
kill them and for which the general
public has a great form of protection in
the form of the vaccines
and to add insult to injury the fact is
that our elites don't even hold by these
rules themselves they just don't
there was video that emerged the other
night of joe biden and joe biden at a
restaurant violating mass mandates and
gensake at the white house tried to
present a a solid front on this but but
failed dramatically
i think what we were referring to is a
photo of them walking out of a
restaurant after they they had eaten
masks in hand where they had not yet put
them back on yet so i would say of
course uh there are moments when we all
don't put mass back on as quickly as we
should but i don't think we should lose
lose a force through the trees here and
that our objective here is to get more
people vaccinated make sure that
that schools and companies around the
country can put in place requirements to
save more lives and keep people safer uh
and you know not overly focus on moments
in time that don't reflect overarching
policy
um how about reflecting on the fact that
if you're an elite in our society and
you're a member of the codery of the
specials you can violate the rules as
often as you want either laura lightfoot
or gavin newsom or joe biden or as it
turns out terry mcauliffe who is writing
amtrak the other day in violation of
federal mandates not wearing a mask
right you're allowed to do all of those
things if you're a special but if you're
a cop just trying to do his job then we
will force you to get vaccinated or we
will fire you if you're a navy seal we
may deploy to the most dangerous areas
on earth to take a bullet for the
country
and you don't want to get the cover
vaccine we'll make you repay all of your
training funding
and none of this makes any level of
sense it is all just authoritarian
nonsense it really is at this point
you're talking about in these cases some
of the healthiest populations in america
you're talking about a disease that does
not kill people
like the smallpox or like
covid remains for the vast majority of
people a somewhat statistically minimal
risk unless you are above a certain age
or have a significant pre-existing
condition that is just the reality okay
i don't know how you designate minimal
risk but if you were told that a
particular action that you had to do
every day driving for example had a 1 in
335 chance of killing you
would you not get in a car like ever
again
how how would you treat that risk right
how we calculate those risks actually
matters so what the media have to do is
they have to scare the hell out of you
to force compliance they have to scare
the living hell out of you so they can't
scare you with the idea that you're
going to die anymore because if you're
vaccinated you're not okay statistically
speaking you're just not okay and they
also can't scare you with the idea that
you're going to kill your neighbor
because again your neighbor is probably
going to vaccinate and if they don't
want to vaccinate that would be their
problem
and if they have a peculiar health risk
and they're an adult then they're going
to be taking measures in any way to
protect their own health if they're
immuno-compromised you know compromised
people live in our society they've been
living in our society for all of time
and they have to take special measures
in order to protect their own health
right this has just been anything for a
very long time but the media have to
come up with some strategy to scare you
into believing the authoritarians who
are in charge of our coveted policy so
the latest point they're using is the
death of colin powell
so yesterday there are a lot of
headlines that colin powell had died
after being fully vaccinated he had two
shots of the vaccine he had not gotten
his booster yet and then he had a
breakthrough case of kovid and he died
and the initial headlines were all about
how colin powell had died of a covet
breakthrough and what a disaster this
was
okay so the initial headlines were like
the vaccines don't work okay that's
nonsense he had multiple myeloma he was
severely immunocompromised he had
parkinson's and multiple myeloma okay so
if you have a severe
immunodeficiency and if you are elderly
as he was he was 84 years old
then if you get a breakthrough case i
mean if you get a cold you could die
from that
right people who are elderly and are
immunocompromised and are already sick
tend to die when they get sick
it doesn't matter whether it's a
breakthrough case of covet or whether
it's regular covet they just die at
higher rates but the media have to scare
you and it's not just about scaring you
if you're elderly they have to scare you
you personally we'll talk about how
they're doing this in just one second
first let us talk about a simple fact
you need a great pair of wireless
earbuds i'm using my wireless earbuds
all the time right i'm listening to
other podcasts or i'm listening to books
on tape or i'm listening to music or i'm
on a phone call i'm using those wireless
earbuds all the time the ones i rely
upon my raycons whether you're using
them to pump up wind down work or work
out raycons are my go-to for on-the-go
audio and the new everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever with an
improved rubber oil look and feel and
optimized gel tips for the perfect in
your fit these are impressive before you
even start listening you get three new
sound profiles to make sure everything
you're listening to sounds its best with
just the right amount of bass there's
also an all-new awareness mode for when
you need to listen to your surroundings
instead raycons offer 8 hours of
playtime and a 32 hour battery life
there's also a built-in mic and you can
take calls on your earbuds at the press
of a button
raycons start at half the price of other
premium audio brands but they sound just
as good and raycon's come with a 45-day
happiness guarantee right now my
listeners can get 15 off their recon
order at biracon.com ben that's
b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n dot com slash ben to
save at 15 on ray cons buy raycon.com
ben okay so as i say
somehow the media and your
authoritarians of covet they need to
come up with a rationale for why you
need to remain extremely worried and now
what they're going to do is they'll
they'll say that states that are read
and have not been as worried are bad
states right florida's a bad state and
then they'll just forget about it when
everything is fine in florida so for
example right now in florida extremely
low transmission rates in fact the
transmission rates of covet in florida
right now which of course is the worst
state in america right it's ron death
santos and all that crap
the transmission rates in in florida
right now are half the transmission
rates in new york you know who predicted
this anyone with a brain because as we
move into winter which is really nice in
florida and people are outdoors in
florida and as we move into winter in
the northeast where it's really gross
outside and people spend their time
indoors the virus will move around
indoors and that's not about covert
policy that is just about reality when
you're indoors in close contact with
other people people get sick more often
it's why for a very long time people
always thought that the way you got my
dad still thinks this okay the way you
get a cold is because you're cold
outside
okay it's not because you're cold
outside it's because you go from the
cold outside to a place where you're in
close contact with other people
and then you breathe on them right that
is why people get sick during the winter
it's not because it is cold outside and
so it's cold and you went outside
without your mittens and then you got a
cold that's not how you got sick okay so
most viruses
are transmitted through close contact
with others close contact with others is
maximized when the weather is ugly
outside
but we have to pretend that florida's
super bad right okay so now they've
moved on from that because florida is no
longer a story because florida the
transmission rates are very low so we're
never going to hear about that again and
you never hear about it when when death
santas is doing fine you only hear about
it when death scientist vaccinates most
of the population and then bad stuff
happens anyway
that's when you have to blame death
stand okay so
the new narrative is you need to
vaccinate so colin powell doesn't die
this is the actual piece over at the
washington post today from philip bump
quote former secretary of state colin
powell died monday morning from
complications related to covet-19
powell's disease resulted from a
breakthrough infection he was fully
vaccinated against covid but instead of
demonstrating that the vaccine isn't 100
effective in preventing death which was
known his death better serves to show
the need to tamp down on coronavirus
cases more broadly to help protect those
most at risk that group included powell
he was 84 years old when he died well
into the elderly age group that has most
been ravaged by the virus he had also
been diagnosed with multiple myeloma
which can reduce the body's ability to
fight infections
last week the cdc released data showing
the effectiveness of vaccines in
curtailing new infections and deaths
from coronavirus in august it found
those who were vaccinated or six times
less likely to become infected and
eleven times less likely to die of
coca-19 but the data also showed a
disparity in the death toll the
incidence of covet deaths among those 80
and over was nearly as high as the
incidents among the unvaccinated age 50
to 64. which again is not shocked that i
don't know we're supposed to be
surprised by that when again people
above the age of 80 die for lots of
reasons because when you're old you tend
to die much more easily than when you
are younger
just the the simple math
says philip bump
older americans have always been at more
risk from code the effect of the virus
are clearly more pronounced with members
of that age group even when they are
vaccinated this should not be an impetus
of to nihilism it is not the case that
this demonstrates that vaccines are
futile or not useful instead it's a
reminder the virus still poses a risk to
the elderly even when vaccinated and
therefore that the goal should be to
tamp down on the spread of the virus
broadly if pell had been at little risk
of contracting the virus because
transmission rates were low he would
have been at almost zero risk of dying
from it but instead his death comes at a
time when more than 80 000 people a day
are still contracting the virus and more
than 1500 people a day are dying from it
about as many people as we're dying in
early april of 2020.
okay now here's the thing if you're
talking about reaching hurt immunity we
have yet to see the country that has hit
quote unquote herd immunity to the point
where there is no transmission of virus
the asymptomatic are transmitting the
virus so barring full-time masking of
everyone and 100 vaccination rates which
none of which is achievable
there will be cases where people who are
immunocompromised come into contact with
virus and then get sick and then die
because unfortunately that is just the
way the world works
when philip bump says we need to force
vaccinate cops so colin powell doesn't
die
i'm sorry but this is not the way we
treat literally any
anthony fauci himself the great god of
kovid anthony fauci has said we have
eradicated to date one disease on planet
earth
the notion that you're going to be able
to eradicate a disease that is currently
circulating in literally millions of
people around the globe
and ensure that everybody who's
immunocompromised is is fully safe
without any protections
that's kind of wild
by the way should you be that worried
about a coveted breakthrough killing you
the answer is no the statistical proof
on this is pretty obvious there have
been 187 million people in the country
have been fully vaccinated
of those 187 million people about 7 200
have died and about 85 of those deaths
were people over 65
and most of those people had conditions
that compromised their immune systems
apparently this is according to politico
and so i'm not sure what you think the
purpose of yelling at people is but
apparently the purpose of yelling at
people is to just intimidate you into
silence
right that's the goal now is any of this
really effective like everybody who
wants to get vaccinated has now been
vaccinated
and the vaccines provide incredible
protection
can we move on at any point here
or is the authoritarianism the point
again i think this is a psychological
problem in half the country right now i
think that a huge number of people on a
financial level on a personal level on a
health level have decided that all risk
is worthy of avoidance
and that in order to mitigate the risk
we have to have somebody who knows
better an expert who crams down on your
neighbors what you can't cram down on
your neighbors yourself
the best way to mitigate risk is to make
sure that your neighbors are controlled
and so you got a media invested in that
ideology you have a government invested
in that ideology there's only one
problem none of it works and in fact you
have unforeseen risks like for example
the risk of crime that goes up when you
fire a bunch of cops
or the risks that the economy dies when
you tell everybody that they are unsafe
when they go back to work
there are a bunch of actual risks that
materialize the moment you say that you
have quashed all risk
the titanic is the same the safest ship
afloat up until the moment it ramps
directly into an iceberg
the thing here is that the iceberg is
completely foreseeable
alrighty in just one second we'll get to
new york city demonstrating once again
that uh they apparently don't want to be
part of the united states we'll get to
that in a second first let us talk about
my love for cryptocurrency okay so i am
an owner of bitcoin i've been doing
great on my bitcoin by the way i am an
owner of ethereum
i i believe in bitcoin because i i
believe in cryptocurrency i think that
cryptocurrency is an excellent way to
hedge against the manipulations of
centralized governments that have the
power to debase the currency
and this is one of the reasons why i'm
working with alto crypto alto crypto
iras allow you to trade crypto like
bitcoin and avoid or defer the taxes you
can get into investing in crypto and do
it in a tax advantaged retirement
account
altos crypto ira is the easy way to get
crypto into an ira you can trade all you
want without the tax headache you can
create an account in just a few minutes
you can invest with as little as 10
bucks there are no set up charges
there's secure trading 24 7 through
alto's integration with coinbase there
are 80 plus coins available including
bitcoin and ethereum and cardano you
want some sushi swap with your bitcoin
no problem alto has you covered industry
leading security they've got the
advanced encryption standard for wallets
and private keys
multiple ways to fund your account you
can make a cash contribution or transfer
cash from an existing ira or roll over
an old 401k you can open an alto crypto
ira account with as little as 10 bucks
just go to altoira dot com slash ben
that's a l t o i r a dot com slash ben
go to alto ira dot com band 2 get
started
alrighty if you've been searching for a
daily morning podcast without an agenda
look no further than morning wire which
has been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its release it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
fact trending toward number one so
subscribe start listening right now to
morningwire on applespotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
meanwhile new york city demonstrating
full scale that trump was right so you
remember that time when there was a big
argument over the robert e lee statue in
charlottesville it was the subject of
that alt-right unite the right rally and
that ended of course in violence and
then there was this very controversial
press conference where trump seemed to
quasi downplay the the evils of the
white supremacists but kind of but then
walk it back but then walk and it was
all a mess right but there's one thing
trump said during that press conference
that was 100 right and the left said
this has never happened he said if you
tear down the statues of robert e lee
jefferson's next washington's next and a
lot of the left david graham in the
atlantic for example we're like no no no
no we're not going after the founders
that would be very silly after all
there's a major distinction between
people who actively fought to
make the country not exist anymore as a
country and people who established the
country and who also participated in the
sins of their time okay now i agree
there is a major distinction between
robert e lee and george washington or
between robert e lee and thomas
jefferson but you know who doesn't agree
a large swath of the left which believes
that all of these people are inherently
bad they're evil white slave holders and
therefore they must be torn down and it
doesn't matter if they established
generalized principles which led to the
foundation of the greatest republic in
the history of mankind nope all that
matters is that they lived as people in
their times and made and were involved
in sins that were fairly common at the
time doesn't mean that they weren't evil
sin is sin but it does mean
that to pretend that we are building
statues to thomas jefferson because of
his treatment of sally hemmings is
idiotic no one is building statues to
thomas jefferson because of that we're
building statues to thomas jefferson
because thomas jefferson was the author
of the declaration of independence
because thomas jefferson helped
negotiate the peace because thomas
jefferson was president of the united
states involved in louisiana purchase i
mean there are lots of reasons to build
statues to thomas jefferson generally
when you build statues to a human you're
not doing so because you're green
lighting every element of what they
believed right this is why we have
martin luther king day every martin
luther king day there's an attempt by
the left to sort of suggest that if you
buy into martin luther king as a figure
as a seminal figure in american history
this must be because you also endorse
his socialistic view of economic
redistribution that's very silly the
reason that we celebrate martin luther
king day is because martin luther king
was calling for a united states beyond
race for people to be judged as
individuals not as groups on the basis
of skin color right that is the main
takeaway when you build a statue you're
looking for the main takeaway not an
endorsement of every aspect of anybody's
life because on that basis nobody should
have a statue there's a famous section
of the talmud where there's a discussion
over whether it be better for people to
have been born or not been born it's a
big debate it's a big philosophical
debate and one side says better for
people to be born because they can
perform commandments and they can
fulfill god's will and the other side's
like not better for man not to be born
because human beings inherently sin and
they send an awful lot and they are
bound to do more bad than good
and the talmud comes down on the side it
would have been better for men not to be
born but since you are born you better
do some it's vote right you better do
some commandments okay that is the view
that you should have toward human nature
and toward building statues of people
okay when it comes to building a statue
of somebody you're not building a statue
to their sin you're building a statue to
the stuff that they did that was correct
okay but nobody seems to be able to make
this particular distinction when it
comes to the left
right if you were a sinner a grave
sinner
from 1790 this means the statue has to
come down even if you were the author of
the words that created the creed that
were foundational to not only the
creation of the united states but also
to the ending of slavery to the civil
rights movement there's a reason that
the words of thomas jefferson echo
not through the slave holding south but
echo through the free north there's a
reason that the words of the declaration
of independence are invoked by people
like frederick douglass and booker t
washington and martin luther king
there's a reason for that but apparently
not to the new york city council which
has not only no historical perspective
but no philosophical understanding
according to the new york times for more
than a hundred years a seven foot tall
statue of thomas jefferson has towered
over members of the new york city
council in their chamber at city hall a
testament to his role as one of the
nation's founding fathers and the
primary author of the declaration of
independence but for the last few
decades some black and latino council
members citing jefferson's history as a
slaveholder called for the statute to be
banished a push that gained significant
momentum in the last year as the nation
has broadly reconsidered public
monuments that can be viewed as symbols
of systemic racism
now again thomas jefferson statues are
not about systemic racism they're about
the words of the declaration of
independence that apply to all human
beings
okay that's the whole point the
declaration of imp the reason that
thomas jefferson was a hypocrite in his
own life is because he knew that he
wasn't upholding his own standards but
that doesn't mean that the standards
were wrong or that his articulation of
the standards was bad the articulation
of the standards is what he was being
held up to
on monday city officials voted
unanimously to remove the statue of
thomas jefferson from council chambers
but delayed a decision on where to put
it presumably we need to put up a statue
of george floyd because that is more
symbolic of the united states a career
criminal who is killed by a cop that is
much more symbolic of the united states
now
you got to notice the illogic here right
there there are george floyd statues
that are now being erected in major
cities around the united states what are
you building the statue of george floyd
too
george floyd led a mess of his life
he put aside how he died his life was in
absolute shambles he was a mess he was a
career criminal who spent an awful lot
of time in jail he was high as a kite
when he encountered the cops on the day
of his fateful death
and you're building a statue to him why
is the statue to all of the bad things
he did in his life or is the statue
supposed to be a commemoration of what
happened to him
right so the philosophy of of how you
build a statue obviously applies to
george floyd but no longer applies to
thomas jefferson and if you're going to
talk about somebody who did more good
for the world thomas jefferson or george
floyd that is not a comparison it is
just not one person was involved in the
foundation of a country the other was a
career criminal who unfortunately died
at the hands of a cop
that is not there's no comparison there
but we're a country that says yes yes on
the statues of george floyd ixnay on the
statues of thomas jefferson good luck to
that country
cigna nielsen president of the public
design commission which oversees art at
city-owned property said quote there are
700 pieces of art under our jurisdiction
we cannot make a rash decision that will
set a precedent for the other 699 pieces
of artwork that may also have challenges
from people or other groups of people
the relocation of the statue requested
by the council's black latino and asian
caucus was expected to be a fate
accompli
i i just i why the asian was thomas
jefferson like super anti-asian i didn't
know about it okay anyway an agreement
was already in place to relocate the
statutes to the new york historical
society a crate had been ordered to
house the statute during the move
the unexpected delay angered some black
and latino lawmakers they're not super
worried about the rising rates of murder
in the city or the poverty and
homelessness in the city of new york but
they are deeply worried that this statue
is in a room with them
because the statue is going to do
something to them it's like the end of
don giovanni is going to emerge from
hell to drag them down or something
there have been various attempts to
remove the statue two decades ago a call
to banish the statue gained detention
but it went nowhere because we weren't
complete idiots 20 years ago
adrian adams councilwoman from queens
said jefferson embodies some of the most
shameful parts of our country's history
yeah so does like all of history
i i'm sorry to break it to adrian adams
but all of human history is replete with
suffering and evil
i mean i'm sure her text messages are
replete with some bad stuff like are we
really going to play this game
this is not a game that is worth playing
opposition to removing the statue began
to surface in recent days a group of 17
historians sent a letter on monday to
the panel suggesting the statues stay at
city hall and simply be relocated to the
governor's room where it was originally
housed for most of the 19th century
a daily news editorial on monday also
questioned the move
removal of the removal is a very simple
solution that will erase the debate said
raymond lavertu a historian at the
rothermere american institute at the
university of oxford
although jefferson was massively flawed
he added his ideas on equality should be
grappled with daily
well yes
but again
trump was right trump was correct
okay the left seems it's bound and
determined like bound and determined to
justify all of the worst expectations of
the rights so the right's like if you
guys take down that robert e lee statue
you'll probably go off for washington
and liberals like nope nah nah nah and
then the left's like no absolutely we
will absolutely 100 we will
we already have the public design
commission voting to remove the theorem
roosevelt statue at the entrance of the
american museum of natural history
despite theodore roosevelt's
contributions to that field
and uh they also have been talking about
removing other statues as well
it's pretty incredible stuff really
great but you know what this philosophy
is alive and well inside the bible
administration so jennifer granholm
who is the secretary of energy
jennifer granholm she was on national tv
and she was talking about communist
china
and she literally said we don't have the
moral authority to call it communist
china you have to understand tearing
down jefferson is part and parcel of an
idea about tearing down america and
suggesting that america on the world
stage has no place this is part and
parcel of what we talked about yesterday
the getting rid of the truth justice in
the american way slogan from superman
the left is intent on the notion that
america is actually morally decrepit
there's something deeply wrong morally
with the united states america does not
deserve to have a place on the world
stage we have to fix all our we have to
make america into utopia in order for us
to be proud of ourselves and the way you
make america into utopia is by sinking
into a socialist morass and being
incredibly surrender oriented in foreign
policy here's jennifer granholm
you know we've got a global problem and
china is a big contributor to that we
are too and but we don't have much um
moral authority to say you should be
doing this if we're not taking action
oh no we do uh we have more authority to
call it china on literally everything
and when it comes to emissions i mean
she here is talking about carbon
emissions we don't have the moral
authority to uh call out china but if
you look at carbon emissions by country
china is far and away far and away the
biggest emitter i mean it's not close
but we apparently do not have the the
ability to call them out
i'm confused as to why that would be
china right now is emitting something
like more than twice as much carbon as
the united states is
they're emitting almost 30 percent of
all carbon emitted on planet earth is
being emitted by china
i mean we could call them out on that if
we wanted to
we could
we're not going to
okay and that is part of a broader
philosophy the broader philosophy of
course being that the united states is
kind of bad and we have to shut up and
by the way china is taking full
advantage of this in the same way the
soviet union did the soviet union while
it existed spent an awful lot of time
talking about the racial problems of the
united states in an attempt to paint
america is terrible and ex and sort of
exercise their own demons at the expense
of the united states
our enemies see the same thing
and fortunately this philosophy has also
penetrated into education which is why
you've seen so much debate in recent
months over critical race theory being
taught by teachers in the public schools
and then the left saying it's not
happening right no no it's not in the
same way that they said they would never
tear down statues of thomas jefferson
now they say we're not teaching critical
race theory in schools yet you're lying
you are teaching critical race theory in
schools the nea has passed specific
resolutions attempting to protect
critical race theory in schools and this
administration happens to be run by the
nea
so for example
the bidens yesterday spent the day
bragging that they had literally
appointed
the secretary of education at the behest
of the national education association so
here is joe biden catering to randy
weingarten who is one of the most
malignant figures in american public
life
and randy
thank you thank you thank you we kept
our commitment didn't we
all right
okay and then you have joe biden
bragging that biden literally appointed
the education secretary at the behest of
randy weingarten now randy weingarten
it's because i've heard that basically
kids missed a year of school last year
we knew full well the kids could be in
school last year and randy weingarten
and the na were pushing hard against it
after
these teachers unions who are run by
extraordinarily far-left people
who do not care about the kids they
teach
these people run this administration
it's amazing here's joe biden just
admitting it
secretary cardona
as you know my husband made a promise to
educators across america
that his secretary of education would be
a leader who taught in a public school
classroom and he found that in you
right randy right becky was our promise
[Applause]
now as our promise we promised the nea
that we would pick somebody who pleased
the nea
yeah we know we know there's a reason by
the way that the teachers unions are so
supportive of democrats and it's because
they continue to democrats continue to
prop up this most corruptive bargains it
is an incredibly corrupt bargain
basically you have states that buff up
the nea and the aft the nea and the aft
then weigh in on elections and try to
get those people re-elected you want to
talk about corruption and campaign
finance reform why is it that nobody
ever mentions the unions which
contribute literally billions of dollars
worth of political infrastructure to
democrats every election cycle here is a
teachers union ad supporting terry
mcauliffe in virginia in this hotly
fraud election
when it comes to education glenn
younkin's not being straight with us his
plan diverts money away from public
schools and gives it to private schools
instead that's why we support terry
mcauliffe as governor he listens to
parents and teachers and scale back
standardized testing giving teachers
more time to teach and kids more room to
learn it's terry mccullough terry
mccallum is terry mccullough we trust to
stand up for our kids the american
federation i'm sure you do political
education sponsored that's paid for by
the aft right the aft is one of the
terrible teachers unions that runs
education in the country i love that the
aft is like also we are super happy that
terry mcauliffe is cutting standardized
testing for kids i'm sure you are it
means that we can no longer tell whether
you're a good teacher or a bad teacher
or whether you're doing your job or not
i've noticed but you can continue to
cram down whatever you want on the kids
i mean terry mcauliffe has openly said
that you the teachers should be the
ultimate experts on what is taught to
the kids not the parents
there's this is all part and parcel of a
broader attempt to teach your kids
garbage that is in line with far-left
thinking
in the indoctrination centers that exist
in our public school system run by the
teachers unions all the way up to the
federal level
are a disastrous
uh they are a disastrous infiltration
into the brains of our young people
and that is not a coincidence that is
all part of the plan all righty we'll
back you later today with an additional
hour of content coming up soon the matt
wall show airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show